YouTube is arguably the biggest and most
influential social media platform in
existence but gone are the days when
YouTube's primary export was funny cat
videos today YouTube is the primary
platform for just about every topic of
video from workout tutorials to beauty
guru feuds and this there's a lot of
cool stuff in here but I am NOT an
energy policy expert so I have fun so
what were you holding gay Lotito from
box that's steven crowder a popular
conservative youtuber making a name for
himself on the platform that video was a
rebuttal to this video by carlos masa a
producer at vox
trump had tweeted a bull claim that the
green New Deal would somehow ban cars
cows in the military
how would you ban a cow while both
commentators are taking jabs at the
other side of the aisle the difference
between their language couldn't be any
clearer this is what mr. gay Vox wants
to do mister let's be queer from Vox box
now he could be a [ __ ] your honor in a
viral tweet thread maza complaints to
YouTube about this harassment and it
removed the videos in question from the
site underlining an effort to make sure
they're hosting a safe and inclusive
platform for creators I'm sorry what
YouTube actually did the complete
opposite YouTube responded to maza by
saying that while it found Crowder's
language hurtful he did not violate its
policies the question here is why not
does YouTube have a responsibility to
regulate this according to YouTube's own
harassment policy videos were Crowder
ridicules maza for being gay should be
removed from the site immediately if you
look at the language of YouTube's policy
it says hurtful language is a potential
justification for removing of
and YouTube you literally use the word
hurtful to describe Crowder's content in
their first response to maza as the
story continued to gain traction YouTube
issued a second response the site
decided to remove ads from Crowder's
channel but it's a lousy punishment for
two reasons
first YouTube already limits
monetization on videos about hot-button
issues that aren't deemed brand safe
even when those videos come from
legitimate news outlets secondly Crowder
doesn't just make money from YouTube ads
under his videos he includes a link to
his online store where you can buy
shirts like this to make this punishment
even weaker YouTube said it would romana
ties his channel if he removed that link
what is the point of punishing Crowder
for making hurtful content if that
content is still available to the public
this entire situation calls into
question YouTube's willingness to
restrict accounts that perform well for
them steven crowder has millions of
subscribers and banks millions of views
with his videos because of YouTube his
influence is strong and his engagement
is high punishing him would limit his
influence which in turn limits YouTube's
reach as a platform with great power
comes great responsibility
YouTube might have started as just a
tool for content creators but the
company acts as much more than that
today
it has an algorithm that recommends and
surfaces videos that lots of people have
already watched dictating what gets in
front of eyeballs it's already doing
things that influence what people do and
don't wash which means it's behaving
much more like a media company than a
simple publishing platform nearly 500
hours of video are uploaded to YouTube
every minute and we watch 1 billion
hours of YouTube content every day so
yeah the power is there but where is the
responsibility in a blog post YouTube
gave another reason why it wouldn't
remove Crowder's videos it says it's
because the point of the videos wasn't
to demean carlos masa this is confusing
and allows for other users to say
hurtful comments with no repercussions
under the guise that those hurtful
comments aren't the purpose of the video
YouTube says it's gonna revisit its
harassment policy but all signs point to
Crowder's videos remaining on the site
by refusing to restrict Crowder's
homophobic and racist comments YouTube
is inadvertently green-lighting the use
of this language in other places on its
platform I haven't even mentioned the
fact that Crowder's followers went on to
harass maza for days this is not okay
for a company whose influence is growing
exponentially they could be setting a
dangerous precedent